Okay, so here we are on our browser. I'm going to
open up those developer tools again, which in Chrome that's just
an, an option. And I think Firefox has fairly similar options.
I don't know about Internet Explorer. When I get this little
JavaScript console, and we don't have to know JavaScript but I
am going to show you one thing we can do. I say
document.cookies, cookie. I can actually get a list of all the
cookies in JavaScript. And then I can actually say document.cookie equals,
visits equals one. There are ten thousand and one. Okay, now I've
just set that cookie. Trust me. And when I reload this page.
Thank you web server. You are the best ever. Pretty
neat huh? We just cheated. So, let's say we actually want to
implement this feature, and we didn't want people to cheat.
Let's talk about how we might prevent people from doing that.